(upbeat funk music)
- Oh hey, are you Brian?
- Are you David?
- [David] Yeah.
- Hey.
- Thank you so much
for doing this.
I really appreciate it.
- It's no trouble to me.
I saw your ad on craigslist.
I know these storage
lockers well,
but this does provide
college credit, right?
- Well it's unpaid,
the rest is up to you,
but aren't you a little
old to be in college?
- Yeah, I'm trying to finish.
What had happened was I
went into a coma in my 20s.
I mixed Ambien with a
Terrence Malick movie.
- You must have been
in a dark place.
- I was.
A theater.
(tape recorder clicks)
- Basically, I need you
to interview me for a podcast.
You know, build some buzz.
I was hoping it'd
happen organically,
but no one booked me on--
- Okay, how about this?
David, tell me about...
- I wrote some
questions for you.
- David,
what do you think of the
current state of comedy?
- Oh I think it's
great, you know?
A lot of diversity.
All types of comics now.
In the old days, it was almost
exclusively funny people.
- Should I laugh?
- If you want to.
- I'm not gonna laugh.
Okay.
David, why do you think
the industry has
scorned you so unfairly?
- Well I wouldn't say that.
I just think Hollywood doesn't
know what to do with me.
It's like if I was 5%
funnier, I'd be a millionaire,
and if I was 30% less funny,
I'd be a multimillionaire.
(exaggerated laughter)
- Okay, David,
the Hollywood establishment
has clearly marginalized you.
What is it that
they're afraid of?
- Well, I've always been
kind of a rebel, you know?
And comics today,
they're not like that.
They all wanna be
on T.V., you know.
If you wanna speak
truth to power,
you gotta get your
teeth whitened.
There's no edge, no
defiance anymore.
In comedy or anywhere really.
Well there is one place.
(wheels squeaking)
(electric guitar music)
- You lost, pal?
- No, I'm just
surprised I'm at--
- The library?
Yeah, it's sick, right?
Ever since all the
dive bars and clubs
turned into like cupcake
shops and condos,
we had to find a new place
to sleep and take shits.
And it's got free internet.
Grab a seat.
- [David] Thanks.
(books bang on the floor)
- So what's your deal,
man, what do you do?
- I'm a comedian.
- What do you mean, like
a clown or somethin'?
- Yeah, it's more like a mime,
if a mime talked.
- What's the point of that?
- Exactly.
- Right on, I guess.
- How did you get
into this scene?
- You know what man?
I just stopped givin' a fuck.
- Could you please--
- Shut up.
- This is a library.
- No, it's not, it's like
a homeless jack off center
that rents films to poor people.
- Look, nobody's happy.
- That was awesome.
Man, 30 years ago, this
is where nerds hung out,
and now it's like the stronghold
of anti-establishment.
- "Whatever satisfies
the soul is truth."
Walt Whitman.
- Well I'm just happy you
guys are here, you know?
Doin' your thing.
- There are no
rules, only options.
- Whitman?
- Nah.
Jerry.
(fly buzzes)
- Is he dead?
- I hope so.
- Cool.
- So there are cool
people at the library?
- Not really, well there
was this one guy, Jerry,
who seemed kinda fun.
- The guy that did heroine?
- Yeah.